[Music]
thank you
one of the ideas articulated in Jr
tolkien's essay on fairy stories that
has probably drawn the most attention
from that particular piece is what he
calls sub creation and it is connected
with what he calls secondary World
secondary beliefs and sub-creators so
we've got four different terms floating
around all closely connected and it
matters what it is being contrasted
against which is not just disbelief or
the realism of the primary world you
could even go too far he thinks with
certain kinds of secondary beliefs and
we'll we'll talk about that in just a
bit when we get to faryon drama so the
concept first starts to get articulated
in the section on children
and he's talking about Andrew Lang who
is you know a great fairy story
collector he produced all these uh
colored fairy books and Tolkien himself
was a reader of these and he thinks that
Lang is fundamentally off base in saying
that
um the fairy stories represent the young
age of Man true to his early loves and
have his unblunted edge of belief a
fresh appetite for Marvel's Tolkien says
a little bit too close identification of
uh belief and and Marvels right and
he says that fairy tales shouldn't just
trade on children's credulity or the
lack of experience children he says are
capable of literary belief when the
story makers aren't as good enough to
produce it and here he says something
really quite interesting
we often talk about the Willing
suspension of disbelief right a choice
to believe in something as integral to
what makes fiction that is things that
are untrue being presented as if they
are true work and Tolkien says this is
not a good description of what happens
what really happens so he's giving us a
metaphysics you could say of or an
epistemology to a certain extent of how
fiction how fairy tales in particular
work and so he tells us that in the kind
of belief that is involved here what
really happens is that the story maker
proves a successful
sub Creator and what does that mean well
the sub Creator makes a secondary World
which your mind can enter and we'll talk
about that in a bit but note that
Tolkien is not saying well anytime that
you do this it's automatically going to
work
successful is a key qualifying term
there there's many people who write
fairy stories or dramas or engage in
other sorts of you know fantasy
projection and it just doesn't come
across as a matter of fact Tolkien is
very critical of attempts to produce
literature specifically for children by
taking good stories in which you know a
secondary world is created and then like
shaving off all of the scary or nasty or
adult bits right so that's that's going
to be unsuccessful right or
maybe you know it does create a
successful secondary world but it's an
impoverished one right that's something
we could explore so he goes on and he
says when you've got a secondary world
inside it what he relates the
Storyteller relates is true it Accords
with the laws of that world you
therefore believe it while you are as it
were inside so as long as you are within
the secondary world and it's enticing
and chanting enough you actually believe
it you can become quite attached for
example to the fates of characters right
uh just to take tolkien's own when uh
Bilbo Baggins and The Hobbit is uh
engaging in the riddle game with Gollum
and there's this threat that Gollum will
kill him and eat him right you know you
can feel a sense of concern even fear
year four billable Baggins because you
believe for a while that that secondary
world is in fact real
so he says you believe it while you're
inside the moment that disbelief arises
the spell is broken the magic or rather
art has failed it might have failed from
the very start for some authors and then
you are out in the primary world again
looking that is a wonderful phrase at
the little abortive secondary World from
outside if you're obliged by kindliness
or circumstance to stay then the
disbelief must be suspended or stifled
otherwise looking and listening would
become intolerable but the suspension of
disbelief he says is a substitute for
the genuine thing a subterfuge we use
when condescending to games of
Make-Believe or when trying more or less
willingly to find what virtue we can in
a work of art that has for us failed so
very interesting the belief that we have
in secondary worlds in sub-creations
is something distinct from the Willing
suspension of disbelief which is a poor
substitute for it he gives you an
example here that you know it might be a
little hard to relate to but just think
about any sort of interest that one
might have a real Enthusiast for Cricket
the sport of cricket is in the Enchanted
State secondary belief
I Tolkien says when I watch A Match I am
on the lower level I can achieve more or
less willing suspension of disbelief
when I'm held there and supported by
some of our other motive that will keep
away away boredom for instance a wild
heraldic preference for dark blue rather
than light this suspension of disbelief
May thus be a somewhat tired shabbier
sentimental state of mind and so lean to
the adult and he says I fancy this is
off in the state of adults in the
presence of a fairy story we watch it or
listen to it or read it and you know
we're like okay that's for kids you know
we don't really buy into it we don't
appreciate it that much so
that's quite a set of important points
that he's making there and he goes on
and he talks about this a little bit
more in the section on fantasy and he
tells us
um that for to begin with that uh
fantasy is this word that is going to
embrace the sub creative art in itself
and the quality of strangeness and
wander in the expression and what's
needed here well we got to distinguish
fantasy from imagination imagination is
part of it right but imagination passes
through
art or craft
or enchantment if you like and then
produces
sub creation the sub creator
can't just have an active imagination
they also need to have some skill they
have to develop their chops so to speak
and if they do then they can create a
successful sub creation and you know it
won't necessarily be successful for
everybody plenty of people can read
Tolkien and be like oh this is silly I
don't like this kind of stuff or any
other uh author you know CJ Chara with
her great Alliance Union Universe Works
you can read them and be like yeah
there's too much detail about how a ship
works or how gravity Works in here it's
leaving me cold but you can also enter
into that secondary world and that is a
product of not just imagination but art
and sub creation so he goes on and he
actually says that fantasy
is uh perhaps the most or at least more
sub creative kind of activity and uh
fantasy is very connected with fairy
tales right so fantasy is more sub
creative but it's also he says more
difficult why
at any rate it's found in practice the
inner consistency of reality is more
difficult to produce the more unlike are
the images and the rearrangements of
primary material to the actual
arraignment Arrangements of the primary
world it's easier to produce this kind
of reality with more sober material he
says so fantasy often remains
undeveloped and it's been used
frivolously merely for decoration it
remains merely fancy full not fantasy
and he says anyone inheriting the
Fantastic device of human language can
say the green sun many can then imagine
or picture it but that's not enough
to make he says to make a secondary
world inside which the green sun will be
credible
will probably
require labor and thought and will
require a special skill a kind of Elvish
craft so you know making the secondary
World believable
commanding what he's called secondary
belief the belief that you have as you
enter into it that is tricky it's easier
to do that with say a spy novel or a
romance novel right because you're
basically just taking what people are
already doing and introducing a few kind
of weird things like you know umbrellas
that shoot bullets or you know vast
plots that you can be part of or the you
know people being attracted to each
other in ways that perhaps doesn't
happen in real life
fantasy is a lot tougher because you've
got a lot more work to do to make that
secondary world credible
so he's you know he goes on and he says
a few attempts such difficult tasks but
when they're attempted in any degree
accomplished then we have a rare
achievement of art indeed narrative art
storytelling as he's going to say in its
primary and most potent mode
and this is why Tolkien perhaps wrongly
depending on how we view this is going
to say that you're you're really going
to do this in literature in words not in
painting or the other plastic Arts not
in drama I suspect he would probably
roll film and TV under drama and he's
got a long section discussing that that
we have addressed elsewhere but it is
important to talk about
one type of drama that he brings up
ferian drama right so there should be a
connection between fairy tales and what
happens in them and that kind of drama
so he says that this can produce fantasy
with a realism and immediacy Beyond the
compass of any human mechanism as a
result now notice what he's going to say
here their usual effect is to go beyond
secondary belief right so it's not
it may be producing secondary belief but
it is also going Beyond it in a way
that alters that secondary belief
this is very important for for Tolkien
he says that if you are present at a
fairy and drama you yourself are or
think that you are bodily inside its
secondary world you're not just reading
a book and you know uh imagining
yourself within that secondary world you
believe yourself within that secondary
World yourself bodily right so he says
that this experience may be very similar
to dreaming and it has it would seem
sometimes by Men been confounded with it
but inferion drama you are in a dream
that some other mind is weaving and the
knowledge of that alarming fact May slip
from your grasp to experience directly a
secondary world the potion is too strong
and you give to it not secondary belief
but primary belief however marvelous the
events you are deluded right and uh this
is for the the designers a form of Art
and distinct from Wizardry or magic so
called the designers don't live in it
though they can perhaps afford to spend
more time in it than human artists can
he's talking about elves here the
primary world real quality of elves and
Men is the same if differently valued
and perceived so you know he's not
saying don't ever indulge yourself in
theory and drama and we might think in
our own time well what would be like
that I mean immersive video games could
be like that right
um he goes on and he says one other
thing that that's quite important and
this is uh in this the section the last
section of the work before the epilogue
he tells us that fantasy
is
at its core made up of the primary world
right fantasy uh the fairy stories are
fantasy at their core and we have to use
the primary world he says
a good Craftsman loves his material and
has a knowledge and feeling for clay
stone and wood which only the art of
making can give and he says fairy fairy
stories deal largely mainly with simple
or fundamental things Untouched by
fantasy but the simplicities are made
all the more luminous by their setting
so
says it was in fairy stories I first
Divine the potency of the words and The
Wonder of the things such as Stone and
wood and iron tree and grass house and
Fire Bread and Wine these are all
material objects right which we could
easily adopt kind of dismissive
reductive attitudes towards so Tolkien
is saying that within the secondary
World these take on a different framing
but he also talks in this very section
about great desires primordial desires
that we human beings have not just to
escape from bad things including death
but also these longings for uh you know
the desire to visit the deep sea the
longing for the flight of a bird and uh
profounder Wishes the desire to converse
with other living things like the
animals right and so these are part of
the primary World part of what makes us
us
and we carry that forward into the
secondary world as Believers or as
sub creators who are developing that
narrative in which for example the
beasts can speak and hold converse with
human beings and each other and not just
hold you know Converse or engage in
discussion or whatever but have laws and
kingdoms and desires of their own so
secondary uh worlds are incredibly
important but also hard to pull off it
takes real Artistry as a sub Creator so
this is uh you know what Tolkien is
actually saying here you notice that
we've had to pull together a number of
different passages from different
sections because he doesn't have a
section specifically on sub creation
secondary worlds secondary belief and
sub creators